the president here says that part of the  problem is that the media does not  report the good news the kids birthday  parties that the banana bread well I  think it's more important for me to be  telling the story what it's like for a  normal rocky family I mean he ain't  telling too many haha good news stories  as he's queueing for gas for two days  when he's going home and his family  hasn't had electricity for three days  and when the market blows up when he  goes to get his banana bread not to be  morbid but I have to ask you if you  spend another three years in Iraq what  do you give your odds of surviving I try  not to think about that bill and I try  to stay as drunk for as long as possible  while I'm here I guess I don't dwell on  you